[Music]
welcome to GameSpot XIII 2018 stage I'm
Matt Padgett and today I am joined by
Patrick Ewing and you have brought a
game for us today called neo cab I'm
very excited to see this I saw this
during the PC gaming show there was a
trailer tell me what is this game about
in neo cab you are Lina Romero you're
the last human driver on the streets of
los ojos which is a city that's been
taken over by autonomous cars it's sort
of a near-future world where nobody owns
their car and like a uber lyft Tesla
type company sort of controls
transportation everywhere and you're
struggling to survive by keeping your
rating up and making enough money to to
survive on the streets of los ojos
awesome well let's take a look at it so
what exactly do you do in this game so
you're a driver and it's a narrative
game where you're trying to sort of
figure out what's going on in the city
and there's always a huge amount of
choice as to who you're going to pick up
next as you navigate around and try to
make it here originally you were staying
with your friend savvy but she's sort of
vanished right after you arrived so I'm
gonna pick up San Lucas now I can see
that he's only a three star passenger so
he's maybe a little bit risky and we got
a series of cinematic camera angles that
tell the story each character is sort of
like a little short story a little
vignette where choices everything so Sam
has just asked me to pick him up in a
basically like a not safe zone and I
have to decide should I risk the money
of like parking illegally and maybe
getting a fine or should I risk losing a
star by taking off my customer and
you're not driving here I see you've got
a single Mouse here that's right you
make driving decisions but it's always
it's like on Rails you're always
choosing your path it's like busy your
path for the city and your path of the
conversation are are made through choice
buttons
so basically I'm just gonna choose what
I feel there and Sam has gotten into the
back of my car
so he's been drinking obviously he's
feeling a little worse for wear
that's me Lena Romero and if you want to
tell me if you wanna you're free to
drive the new air def that's I mean
that's most of my life is adjusting to
the smell of drunk
yeah and apologies for my coffee breath
I know it's it's a poignant cocktail so
so you know we're just making small talk
here and you'll see I've got a feel grid
bracelet here which is a future of
peripheral it's like a biometric thing
that reads your emotions so purple is a
way so he just said he saw puke in the
back of the car enough people are able
to read this at home but he's claiming
he just found some puke in my back seat
but I'm pretty sure it
yeah and that's actually some
procedurally generated content that's
different every time we was yeah yeah
he's kind of a gross character and now
he just threw up in my car what am I
going to do about this guy now you see
my field grid bracelet is changing to
red that means I'm angry and upset at
him and there's actually gonna change my
dialogue options it's gonna change the
whole tone of the ride and that's of
course gonna influence my rating at the
end of it absolutely yeah so he do you
ever pick up people who are just like
they are not going to give you a good
rating no matter what there's always
some puzzle to it and we kind of see
every passenger as a puzzle with this
guy I mean spoiler alert there's no way
to win with him essentially the best way
to win is to just let him get his way
and then he's not gonna piss you off as
much but the the more that I fight him
on this the more he's gonna deny it in
increasingly ridiculous ways he's just
not going to give an inch and so a big
part of our game is that sort of
emotional intelligence of reading people
reading the facial emotions we've spent
so much time on the animation that you
can read people's like moods as they
change both the player character and the
passengers and he's sort of smirking at
me now like I'm not going to be able to
win with this guy
the best I can do is kind of cut my
for sure which I mean we've all been
there with some people yeah yeah and
some late night lift rides I've met some
pretty messed up characters oh yeah so
I'm gonna push him one last time
push them yeah
Wow okay yeah so that's kind of the core
loop of neo cab I'm going to clean up
puke and back of my car which is a great
way to start your first night in los
ojos I could also have paid money to
clean it up and yeah the core loop then
is that he's going to give me a rating
and that's going to directly feed into
my gameplay real lyft and uber drivers
actually will be fired immediately if
their rating drops below 4.8 for a
significant amount of time Wow yeah okay
yeah Wow that is yeah it's pretty this
is an education hour of just maybe me
Wow yeah I know it's pretty rough so
this one star rating could really knock
me out for several rides this is gonna
change how I deal with every passenger
after this you know and I only made six
bucks from this terrible ride so yeah
that's neo cab that's the core loop it's
just meeting interesting people and sort
of seeing where the where the game takes
you so I'm guessing you did you do a lot
of research for like uber yeah we talked
to a ton of people in the gig economy
uber drivers lyft drivers we also
watched a ton of taxicab confessions I
don't know if you remember that show
that is an excellent yeah yeah but it's
it's amazing the intimate space of a car
really makes people open up you know and
they will tell stories to a stranger
that they might not tell their best
friend or their partner oh yeah so that
was really exciting for us for a
conversational game of somebody gets in
and they've got a problem they've got
something they need and the puzzle as a
player of trying to figure out what that
is and figure out their story and then
in our game you have the choice to pick
them up again or just drop that
storyline entirely like I kind of
compare it to in West world when the
milk-can rolls up to you
you know like Dolores like drops the
milk and watch that show it's your
choice to pick it up and that's pulling
a narrative thread that's gonna lead you
to a whole different story in neo cab
it's a big city with like a million
stories and you just sort of pick which
one which thread to to follow
okay and is there it will you ever like
come to a point where you have failed
and you have to start the game over
we do have a game over state I would say
that it's very we give you lots of
opportunities to course-correct
right so if someone gives you a one-star
rating we're gonna give you the
opportunity to have a really nice
passenger who if you treat them well
you're gonna get a better rating if your
emotional state drops there's things you
can spend your money on to boost your
feel grit up again so I'm currently kind
of mad at this woman who's like way over
done with her makeup right now she looks
like that's a good ref with that lip
yeah I mean who does it maybe in the
future though I mean this is a
near-future game so maybe they've become
recognized as the cinematic masterpiece
maybe maybe they are the good ones every
Star Wars movie coming out every single
year you know that's a future I'm
willing to live in and what we're gonna
learn from her is that she's only known
her boyfriend on snapchat her whole time
and so he's never seen her without one
of those 3d filters so she's tried to
make herself up to look as much like her
snapchat filter that she created
yeah you know and and so this is a ride
where you're gonna be able to give her
advice on whether she should you know be
herself be her sort of creative self or
maybe somewhere in between and this is
gonna influence how her date goes and
then basically how her story goes for
the rest of the of the game that's
awesome do you ever like will there be a
point where maybe we picked this woman
up and she's with the guy or do you ever
like dream meet people use absolutely
yeah yeah we have a huge amount of
branching stuff so like there's even a
ride in the build now we're a couple get
in and they're on their first date and
they get into a big fight like a classic
like political fight and you can't it's
but you can try to stay out of it but
basically you're gonna have to pick a
side and then the other person gets out
of the car and now you might find the
person who's left asking you on a date
you know oh wow okay and you can imagine
this really changes the next time you
see the the jilted lover how are they
going to respond to you you know and it
all all of these like random stories or
these like side stories feed into an
overarching narrative which is your
friend has
and under mysterious circumstances and
so you were trying to figure out where
she is is she okay and what's really the
story in los ojos with with these
autonomous vehicles and this like this
megalith corporation that runs them for
sure so I'm very interested I feel like
this is very much in the same vein as
like papers please where you are around
you are going to be like I I know that I
bring all my problems to lyft drivers
make them decide what I'm gonna do yeah
and I feel like that can't I can't be a
good you know I may be getting like
three stars this is right right papers
please is a great reference yes yeah
yeah the struggles of trying to be a
good person while doing a job that has
really tough constraints on you is I
think we'd something we can all relate
to you know like sometimes your job is
just gonna push you to do something that
you wouldn't normally do and that that
complicates the story in a way like if
you played Mass Effect it's those games
I love them but there's often like a
clear distinction like are you gonna be
the good guy or you're gonna be the
badass and you know that's the kind of
choice that's set up in neo cab it's
much more about how how are you being to
this person moment to moment when your
rating is one-star maybe you can't do
someone a solid when you're but when
you're filled grid is growing bright
green now which means I'm like happy and
chill that means maybe I can put out
like more be more emotional receptor to
this person and help her out in a way
that's like more complex Oh double cute
yeah that's actually you drive man yeah
yeah you should not let me drive yeah
all right so let's let's let's drop this
this person off
hopefully there they'll have a good date
yeah yeah there's nothing wrong with a
screen boyfriend Yeah right I mean
there's yeah
dating is hard enough as Geralt from The
Witcher
oh yeah he's your BAE it's burned into
my memory oh so now we can see her
without her makeup so just yeah yep yep
and let's hope that that works out for
her fiona is one of our favorites of our
of our large cast of characters that's
awesome yeah so we're currently
definitely doing Mac and PC we are
looking into consoles and we just start
talking to people so no promises there
and like I can't commit to a time but
I'll say if the game is really far along
and it'll be out when it's done that's
excellent well I'm very excited to see
more of it I'm so grateful you brought
it here
thanks for coming I hope you have a
great recipe three and thanks again for
showing up thanks for having us that's
awesome thanks man yeah
[Music]
you